we have thanksgiving right around the
corner you have a lot to be grateful for
this year mrs shelton that is very true
that is very true we leave next week to
go um to oklahoma we it's a tradition my
whole family flies out and um we have
not been back there since the wedding so
i'm really looking forward to it and we
have a new house there we have like a
new life there so it's gonna be it's
gonna be our first married thanksgiving
very grateful very excited what will it
look like in the kitchen at the shelton
household on thanksgiving who's doing
the cooking we all we all cook my mom
definitely likes to do her turkey her
way blake likes to experiment with
multiple smaller turkeys i think this
year they did like the hot cheetos
turkey one year and then this year i
think they're doing bacon wrapped i i
don't know it's all the boys are talking
about the different things they're gonna
do but every i know one thing is we
never did mac and cheese but we're doing
mac and cheese yeah that's like the new
added every year i feel like we add
something new in so well that's also the
beauty of newlywed life too you get to
create your own traditions as you go
what will that look like for christmas
wow christmas um i we were just talking
thanksgiving i'm like my head um
honestly we do have a tradition that we
do we do um the timpano dome i don't
know if you've heard of it it's this
like layered pasta italian dish and um
last year we screwed up guys i'm sorry
it was a mess so i'm hoping to you know
make something that to make up for last
year and um we were gonna make sure that
we did everything from scratch and it's
just we love doing it we love making the
memories christmas is all about making
the memories and so um it's it's really
fun and we're really looking forward to
it we go big we're gonna go big we're
going to go big speaking of going big
notes for blake shelton what does gwen
stefani want for christmas
ooh you know what um i thought about
this a lot blake
um
you did great you did great no i just
honestly
i just want everyone to be happy and
have that moment you know what i'm
saying it feels like there's a lot of
stress in the air and i just want my
kids to have just the most great
memories that we could ever make
together this christmas and i i know
that we'll be able to do that i love
seeing like the smile on your face you
just seem like you're in the best phase
of your life would you say that's true
i'm in the best phase of my life and i'm
at disneyland right now okay
[Music]
[Music]
baby you make it feel like christmas
thank you for having us here in your
holiday celebrations welcome to my
backyard disneyland anaheim girl here
it's really amazing to be here right
here i mean guys you hear the train
right in the background that's happening
this is real that's the small world
right there so we're pretty excited you
mentioned obviously it is your back your
backyard basically you grew up in
anaheim how good does it feel do you
still geek out when you come here i
still geek out
i got to go backstage guys over there
it's really exciting even back there um
it's just one of those things that for
me like my parents used to like pick us
up from school and be like driving down
harvard boulevard going oops we made the
wrong turn we i guess we have to go to
disneyland today and not go to school so
it's just one of those things that we do
every year we didn't get to go last year
i bring the kids every single year at
christmas time so
um i know that they would be like
freaked out to know i'm actually here
right now
they're going to be like why didn't you
bring us so as teenage boys they still
feel that magic i think it's hard i
don't think at any age you get over
coming to disneyland you know what i
mean it's just you grow up especially
someone that grew up in anaheim you know
it's just a big deal there's a reason
why they call it the happiest place on
earth it really it there is it's true in
fact i'm going to go find a churro as
soon as we're done that's exactly what i
told our producers i'm going to get a
churro after this so we'll go find our
churros
yeah and i was thinking about it too
because i got to get all dolled up to do
the performance and it's like an
afterthought but i feel like my outfit
was very inspired by all those dolls in
the small world like i used to go
through that ride and be like it's right
behind us guys that's a small world and
just be like wow these dolls like i want
to be one of those little dolls and i
get to be one here at disneyland today
well you also are giving me holiday
bride vibe you know i was thinking the
same thing i did not choose this
somebody said hey what about this i was
like okay that looks like almost like a
holiday pride vibe like what you're
saying so in an 80s kind of way right
shoulder pads bringing back the shoulder
what's happening
with the performances what can we expect
you know i think for me
having a holiday album is is it's
surreal because just when you kind of
forget the songs and you sort of like
aren't thinking about it you get to
perform again and it's like wow this
record is just so great it's kind of
thing where you add to it every year you
get to bring new songs into it and so to
be able to revisit it again and do it
live it's just been super fun
[Music]
is it getting you even more into the
holiday spirit it definitely is i think
just even driving down here last night
going on the five freeway and seeing all
the lights going up and we put our
lights up yesterday and
it's almost i said i said to my friend i
was like i feel like because this year's
been so crazy everything feels more
intense and every you feel more grateful
than ever i mean truly we do i just it's
part of the silver lining i guess if
there is one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you feel like this magic in the air
seeing everything
i do and i i what's freaking me out the
most is um
that that that noise like that is
haunting me i'm like i know that noise
it's it's crazy it's just everything
everything is the same that it's always
been but yet christmas time i feel like
is the best time to come here because
they just make it so beautiful i mean
the decorations are like flawless and
i'm super inspired we just need some
snow
yeah that would be that would be cool
that would be really cool now obviously
after the holidays are over in 2022 you
are going to be performing at the super
bowl fest with your husband what is the
best part about being able to perform
together
um honestly
i want to do everything with him every
day so anytime we can be together
perform write songs hang out watch tv
whatever it is i'm all about blake so um
but to be able to be part of the super
bowl thing is huge because he is a major
football freak i mean we were talking
earlier it's like he watches every
single game he has his fantasy football
thing and then he like watches everyone
talk about what they watched on the game
like all day and i'm like okay you're
insane but um so i think it's going to
be fun to be part of that because he's
such a fan and like i have my three boys
they love football it's
they bond with him over football i mean
i did the super bowl back in the day
with no doubt and i think that at the
time i just was not connected at all to
the sport so i didn't even realize what
a big deal it was but then later when i
had my kids i was like hey did you know
mommy played the super bowl like i was
like trying to use it as like cards to
be cool and so now the more that life
goes by i'm really getting more into
football and so to be part of this it
will be it will be fun people are really
fired up heading into the new year what
message do you have for fans just for a
new chapter 2022. okay well you guys as
you say um i just want to say you know
what thank you for the vegas residency
you guys came out that was incredible
thank you for listening to my music all
these years and i think that next year
we got some promise guys it's going to
be good i got some stuff up my sleeve
it's going to
gonna be fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you